want to turn to another legal case that
is making a lot of headlines and a lot
of emotions and a lot of emotion for all
of us attorney Michael avenatti who is
denying trying to extort money from Nike
avenatti is of course accused of
threatening to reveal damaging
information about the sports giant if it
did not pay him millions of dollars this
is what avenatti told Jericka Duncan
about that case you say you were working
on behalf of your client but you were
also telling Nike according to this
complaint you either hire me or I'm
going to say something if what they've
alleged constitutes extortion you're
gonna have to go around the country and
arrest tens of thousands of lawyers in
this country for extortion but there are
legal experts who say you crossed a line
and there's legal experts that say that
I was well within the line as an
aggressive attorney there's many that
say that and the fact of the matter is
this was not extortion people make
threats all the times people make
threats all the time in connection with
trying to settle a case whether it be
what's that you said it was not
extortion was not explored what was it
it was attempting to settle and resolve
a dispute on behalf of a client and make
sure that the right thing was done your
legal expert are there tens of thousands
of lawyers across the country doing what
Michael avenatti alleges not exactly I
certainly think that there are many
aggressive lawyers throughout the
country who will yell and scream and
threaten that if you don't settle this
case
you're gonna be found liable and you're
gonna wind up paying me tens of millions
of dollars I mean that's very typical
I've had people scream at me from time
to time while I was practicing law in
settlement negotiations but I've never
heard and this is where in the New York
case as opposed to the California case
which is much more straight up in the
New York case he does have a defense and
he was very good in this interview with
Jericho he has calm he is thoughtful he
explains that this is what lawyers do
and I'm sure there are a lot of lawyers
who will agree that you can be tough and
he's a good lawyer who has gotten some
big settlements but I go back to where I
started on this case it's one thing to
be a tough negotiator
it's another thing to do a squeeze play
into time that you have to get this
answer to me or I'm going to expose you
on Monday
for your bad conduct and I want a
million-five for my client but I want
twenty two million five from me
Ricci cream in the legal news don't stop
around here listen I have job longevity